[Música]
es la oración del viernes en esta
mezquita en las afueras de valència en
el norte de francia el sermón es
predicado por un joven imán de la región
en su discurso en árabe francés dice que
está consternado por el asesinato del
profesor samuel para ti
es ante todo una profanación del mensaje
profético pero también es una afrenta
para nosotros y para nuestra religión
un mensaje de paz en línea con la
formación de imán que recibió no en
francia sino en marruecos cada mezquita
necesita tener un imán capacitado un
imán competente que sepa cómo transmitir
estos importantes mensajes al apóstol
fue en rabat donde pasó tres años en
este instituto financiado por el
gobierno marroquí
lo conocimos hace unos meses cuando se
estaba formando con mi mano
lo que está relacionado con lo que
sucede en la mezquita ya sea la llamada
a la oración la dirección de la oración
la predicación del viernes se nos enseña
aquí en el instituto
en este instituto algunos estudiantes
son franceses marruecos cubre todo el
costo de sus estudios y les da algo de
dinero
cada mes recibimos una subvención de
2010 lo que equivale a unos 200 euros
además durante las vacaciones de verano
el instituto paga los boletos de avión
todos los alumnos de esta clase
provienen del norte de francia aprenden
el llamado islam del camino intermedio
un islam que busca promover la
tolerancia
nuestro objetivo es luchar contra el
islam radical porque el islam radical no
tiene nada que ver con el islam justo e
histórico
desde hace cuatro años el instituto
mohamed sexto ha formado unos 50 imanes
franceses una solución que en principio
era temporal y que sólo compensa en
parte las clases de formación de
predicadores en francia francia sólo
tiene tres institutos islámicos lo que
es muy poco
de los tres mini manes que practican en
el territorio la mayoría han sido
educados en el extranjero en un país
musulmán y 300 de ellos son imanes
destacados enviados y pagados por
turquía argelia y marruecos
con el riesgo de que algunos de ellos
desprecian los principios franceses
estos imanes aunque tienen cualidades y
conocimientos teológicos no
necesariamente tienen el contacto con
las generaciones más jóvenes que
prefieren ir a internet donde encuentran
discursos fundamentalistas francia ya no
quiere imanes extranjeros en su
territorio y como la ley de 1905 le
impide intervenir directamente en la
formación religiosa el país les impide a
los representantes musulmanes que
establezcan una certificación para las
formaciones existentes
es importante que los fieles sepan que
su imán está aprobado y que fue educado
para predicar correctamente que están a
salvo de alguien que se autoproclama o
cuya formación no cumple con los
estándares requeridos se espera que en
el nuevo año escolar surjan varias
asociaciones entre universidades y
mezquitas pero pasarán muchos años antes
de que todos los imanes de francia se
formen en el país